on the field this week big cat
week 10 who's under pressure it's our
friday tradition because they didn't
text me the trivia question i assume you
are asking me an incredibly difficult
question that i will not know the answer
to and you'll have the first pick in the
draft okay it's not actually a difficult
question it's a question to find out if
you are aware of this nfl season so phil
rivers had played 10 games this year and
leads the nfl in passing yards
aside from rivers who leads the nfl in
passing yards who's number two right now
matt ryan
come on mike
thought it was matt
it's tom brady
matt ryan's not even in the top five
i thought i thought well you know why
they haven't played they've played one
last game all the guys who are up there
have played nine well and also matt ryan
matt schaab played a game
yeah i don't oh that's right that's a
terrible play
the falcons have the number one passing
offense that's i thought it was some
sort of a trick
the fellow who had the top passing
offense phil rivers tom brady russell
wilson matt stafford aaron rodgers
that's your top five right there matt
stafford my dark horse mvp
okay most people
all right most pressure let's start it's
every single week mike it is every
single week i actually don't think
there's any pressure on mitch trubisky
because the jury's kind of out on him
the pressure is on matt nagy because if
the bear season if the bears do not win
another game if the bears go maybe
let's even say one in seven down the
stretch matt nakey could be in trouble
could he not because the expectations
were so high this year and they have
failed so significantly so i think matt
nagy is under pressure whether it's he
should bench mitch trubisky and start
and put in chase daniel to make this
offense look like a real offense or
change up how they run the offense
through mitch trubisky so they can get
the most out of him matt nagy was
brought to chicago to be an offensive
guy he was brought to chicago to get
mitch trubisky on track both of those
things have failed so i think the rest
of this season
and especially this week especi against
the team that they should be able to
beat at home matt nagy's under pressure
you know uh ben mcadoo got whacked
during the season after he took the
giants to the playoffs right and the
giants lost in the playoffs and then it
kind of hovered over them and they went
through that whole eli manning thing and
when do you bench him it was just one
bad mistake after another for ben mcadoo
and actually you know he's gone so i
don't rule out anything at this point
maybe matt neggie could get whacked
during or after the season because he is
supposed to be the offensive genius and
he clearly isn't and just because he's
one coach of the year that doesn't mean
anything that doesn't give you lifetime
job security plenty of guys who have won
coach of the year have ultimately been
fired not necessarily the next year but
at some point you have to ask yourself
maybe it's not trubisky maybe it is
maybe it isn't maybe
matt naggy isn't using trubisky the way
that he needs to use trubisky and and
this is one of the great uh disconnects
for a lot of coaches you have your
system and you become so beholden to
your system you don't want to make it
flexible to suit the guys you have
the best
coaches
take the guys they have and design the
system and the plays and the strategy to
fit the skills and abilities of the
players they have so if trubisky isn't
working in nagi's offense then neggie
needs to revise his offense to get the
most out of trubisky period and at some
point it is on it is on nagi do the
things that trubisky can do don't do the
things he can't do and that's the end of
it and that's that's the simplicity of
it and that's lost on negan so i agree
with you on that all right first pick
for me i mean
we had his picture on the graphic at the
start of the hour for the pr of course
it's kirk cousins it has to be kirk
cousins this is the latest chance for
him to break the narrative just like
tony romo used to have that narrative
that in a big spot in a big game he
would throw an interception or fumble
the ball or fail to execute the hold on
a potential game-winning field goal
that's when it first popped up and it
stayed with him for years and he
eventually broke that narrative this is
the latest chance for kirk cousins to
break it and the longer it lasts the
harder it is because you're more aware
of it each and every time and and he's
if he doesn't do it now then
when they play the seahawks on a monday
night coming up in a few weeks it's
going to be even worse when they play
the chargers on a sunday night unless
that game gets flexed week 15 it's going
to be worse when they have the packers
on monday night week 16 it's going to be
worse he's got to break it because every
time he fails to break it the harder
it's going to be to break it the next
chance he gets okay i like that pick i
had it as well so we agree there uh my
next pick is going to be pat shurmur the
new york giants head coach which uh i
don't know if he's going to be that head
coach for long he's playing the jets
this weekend the dynamic in new york
will always be the giants are the
premier franchise and the jets are kind
of the little brother so pat shirmer
where the wheels are kind of falling off
for the giants you know they had the
daniel jones switch they look like they
had some life they have been bad and bad
coaching ever since if they lose to the
jets who are reeling themselves i think
that is a big big big problem for pat
shurmur you mentioned ben mcadoo who got
fired uh after going to the playoffs
here's something that links pat shermer
and ben mack do as well uh mike other
than just benching eli manning i
mentioned this
quote earlier in the show dan duggan who
is a reporter for uh i don't know where
he is but he covers the giants he said
that when at the press conference pat
shermer was asked how losing wears on
him he said i'm built for this right
ben mcadoo three weeks before he was
fired when talking about losing
i'm built for this so oh god
yeah yeah there's precedent here mike
the guy who benches eli manning the guy
who says i'm built for this when talking
about losing that guy ends up fired i
think this will be an embarrassing loss
for the giants if they can't beat the
jets here and there will be a a a
conversation that's going around in the
city and people will start talking that
pat shurmur needs to go
yeah and you know i i feel like whoever
loses this game the head coach is going
to have more pressure i feel like for
whatever reason though until woody
johnson comes back from the uk where he
serves as the u.s ambassador
gace is going to have a little bit of
leeway because of the contract because
of joe douglas there is the gm and
douglas was hired by gays they're going
to get another year i think i don't know
if it continues with the dysfunction
that we've seen in recent weeks maybe
not but i'm going to stay in that same
game and i'm going to go to the
quarterback sam darnold because he's the
guy who was the hand-picked franchise
quarterback to turn the jets around and
he's got an apples to apples opportunity
to compete with daniel jones even though
they're never on the field at the same
time it was always brady and manning
it's this guy versus that guy
quarterback versus quarterback who's the
franchise quarterback daniel jones has
looked much better this year than
darnold and donald had that great game
in his first game back from mono nfc or
afc excuse me offensive player of the
week in the win over the cowboys since
then seeing ghosts the following monday
night he's fallen apart he's got to have
a good game against daniel jones or the
narrative in new york is going to be the
giants got their franchise quarterback
and the jets blew their chance to do it
okay that's a good pick that is a good
pick uh yes sam darnold
it's
not only sam darnold been struggling but
it's the same things that were
happening at usc and that makes you
nervous it's actually the interception
bowl between sam darnold and dale jones
both guys the big red flag was turnovers
in college and both guys have been
turnover prone in the nfl all right my
last pick mike i'm gonna go with my guy
and i hope we can pick it up i hope we
can play well it's baker mayfield
because the the talk in cleveland i
think a lot of the blame has been on
freddy kitchens i think he has gotten a
lot of
uh the well this guy needs to go
baker is going to eventually be under a
lot more heat as things you know get
worse and worse unless the browns start
winning right now so i think he's under
pressure i think he
more than anyone on that team wears the
losses in terms of it affects him and
i'm saying that in a good way i want a
guy like baker mayfield who shaves his
mustache and says i don't deserve this
mustache and i want to win so bad it
makes me sick that's the type of guy you
want as your franchise quarterback i
think he's taking these losses worse
than anyone on the browns again in a
good way because he cares that much so i
think he's going to come out and he's
going to play very well on sunday but he
is under pressure
yeah i agree with you he's under
pressure and i do think that he will
play well and that the browns will get
their third win of the season whether
that continues we'll see i'm gonna go
you know if we're gonna talk about
quarterback duels
jared goff versus mason rudolph should
be an easy win for jared goff but to go
into heinz field in november in
pittsburgh and we saw what happened to
goff last year when he had to go to
soldier field now the forecast could
have been worse as of right now the wind
chill when you factor in how it's going
to be but it's going to gust up to 20
miles an hour right during game time
it's going to be in the mid 40s that's
how it's going to feel for jared goff
and let me tell you if that's the
official pittsburgh forecast it's going
to be five to seven degrees colder it's
going to feel five or seven degrees
colder at heinz field on those rivers
that and that that turf you know it's
better than it used to be but it's it's
a tough tough place for the visiting
team especially a california team in
november with a quarterback who has a
track record of not playing well
in those moments where the weather
conditions aren't ideal it could be like
i said could be a lot worse it's not
supposed to rain it's not going to be
really cold i mean they could have hit a
window here over the last week or so
where it would have been a lot more
difficult for jared goff but this is his
first test this year outside where it's
not perfect conditions and the
pressure's on him to outduel mason
rudolph who based on how mason rudolph
has looked for most of the time that
he's played this season jared goff
should be able to do it if it was in l.a
it's a no-brainer it's in pittsburgh and
i think goss gonna have his hands full
i like the turf talk there the turf it's
it's okay but it's not as bad as it used
to be but it's you know it's all right
so okay that's fine i don't think that's
an accurate description
that's an action that's that's that's an
accurate that's an accurate uh
description of the quality of the turf
in pittsburgh don't you you don't think
jared goff's under pressure no he's i
mean every quarterback's under pressure
every single week but the other thing
that i don't agree with is that jared
goff playing poorly in he's got a track
record of playing poorly in bad
conditions it was i mean it was one game
last year against the bear that's a
track record that's it there's your
tracker come on you're a stats guy you
know how many times have you been on the
track
how many how many times has he been on
the track that's his track record
disappointed in you mike
when we return i'm going to tell
everybody how much big cat bet on the
raiders last night before we do that
though big cat's got matt and eggy patch
sherman baker mayfield for the most
pressure in week 10. i've got kirk
cousins sam darnold jared goff
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports